welcome back to las vegas now it's time
to get cooking
with nanny bubbe's kitchen and garden
today she's sharing a make ahead meal
for the perfect marinated flank
steak let's check it out you caught me
pulling out tonight's dinner from the
freezer i made this
weeks ago let me show you how easy it is
to make a dinner
freeze it and then when you have a tight
night
pull it out and have the best dinner
ever
welcome back to nanny bubby's kitchen of
course we're always thanking our sponsor
chapman automotive for sponsoring our
segments here he is
all over the kitchen i just love that
and
today we are making flank steak but i
want to tell you
that the key to this recipe is when you
make the marinade
you have to freeze it at least for 24
hours
is the key to making this delicious what
that marinade does to the meat
when it's frozen is like anything you
have ever tasted
so let's get started well we are
starting out today's recipe with about a
two to three pound flank steak
but just so you know you can use this
marinade on chicken
you can use it on salmon i double the
recipe and use it for a big
beautiful beef tenderloin freeze it for
two days and then bring it out and cook
that for company or family coming over
it works beautiful remember the key to
this recipe
is freezing the marinade and the meat
together for at least
24 hours my favorite is two days
so we have our flank steak we're gonna
first blot
all of the juices right out of it
because that way we don't have anything
mixing into the
marinade we're now gonna simply
take salt and pepper to both sides
we are going to now add the ingredients
for our marinade
we are going to add 2 tablespoons
of white vinegar
[Music]
2 3 cup of soy sauce
make sure that your soy sauce is organic
and make sure that it is naturally
brewed you want a brewed soy sauce
then we're taking 2 tablespoons of sugar
already measured out
one two i'll pour the rest of it in
because it's hard to get it all
out then we're going to add
a half teaspoon of garlic powder now you
know
i love to always do whole fresh
ingredients
but with this recipe you need something
that's going to dissolve into this
liquid
and garlic would just stay chunky
that's a mouthful isn't it so here we go
here's the garlic powder
and then not to contaminate the spoons
another half
teaspoon of ground ginger and we're
using the ground rather than the fresh
ginger for the same reason
and then we're gonna whisk this up
[Music]
keep whisking until it's nice and
dissolved
so you can do one of two things you can
either use a two and a half gallon or
one gallon ziploc bag freezer bag makes
certain
or we use these food saver bags which
help to really burp out all of the air
i'm not sure if you're familiar with
foodsaver but
there's just an example of it and what
you want to do is put your meat in
first because it's less messy that way
meat goes in there we go
marinade one last whisk to make sure
it's dissolved
gets poured right into the bag
[Music]
we're gonna take this and stick it in
the freezer
for about a day or two is best
and then it's there and ready i'm
telling you
that and i don't know why it is but
freezing this
makes all the difference in the world so
normally i would put this
on the grill for about 12 minutes per
side but you can see nanny bubby's grill
is under construction right now
so follow me into the house and let's
throw it under the broiler for the same
12 minutes per side
and there you have it the beautiful
flank steak
smells delicious pairs beautiful with
this risotto
which we're going to make in two weeks
from now with spring greens in it
it's absolutely delicious these are your
tiger pumpkins
buy them now because they won't be here
in november when we teach you how to
make soup bowls for thanksgiving out of
this
and now off to a fabulous glass of pinot
and a
wonderful marinated flank steak see you
in a couple weeks
oh looks so good check out nanny bubby's
kitchen and garden on social media and
online at nannybubby.com
we also want to thank chapman automotive
for sponsoring this segment